we begin with what's next for the u.s
after president biden's historic meeting
in geneva
with russian president vladimir putin
the president is now back at the white
house
after a week overseas that ended with
yesterday's summit
mr biden says he did accomplish his goal
of restarting diplomacy with a major
adversary of the united states
but it's not yet clear if any measurable
progress was made on issues like
election interference
and cyber attacks ed o'keefe is in
geneva for us ed good morning to you the
two men spoke for hours
what do we know about what came out of
it
well good morning tony from what they
call the city of peace and you see here
on the local
front page of the tribune de geneve la
trevid
le trev de geneve the truce of geneva
coverage spreads across several pages
here as it does around the world this
morning among other things
the us and russia agreed to allow their
ambassadors to go back to moscow
and washington a sign of modest progress
but as the president said himself
it could be several months until we know
whether this summit was worth it
and whether russia changes its behavior
i did what i came to do returning to the
white house overnight president biden
seemed pleased after his three-hour
summit with russian president putin
the tone of the entire meetings good
positive the two leaders emerged with
some potential compromises
they planned to start a strategic
dialogue on the future of nuclear
weapons
and discuss the fate of american
prisoners being held in russia
the question about american citizens
russian prisons we discussed that
there
but the two signaled they're still at
odds over issues like cyber security and
human rights
putin has a history of quashing dissent
in jailing political enemies like
russian opposition leader alexey navalny
who's been imprisoned for months
putin refused to even utter navalny's
name
this person knew that he was preaching
the business effective in russia
while the president warned of what could
happen if navalny dies in prison
i made it clear to him that i believe
the
consequences of that would be
devastating for
russia putin also said political dissent
in his country could lead to what he
called america's
disorder slamming everything from gun
violence
to the black lives matter movement
disorder destruction violations of the
law
et cetera and he equated arresting
political protesters with the arrests of
rioters at the january 6th capital
attacks
that's ridiculous comparison they're
very different
criteria putin also refused to
acknowledge russia's role in recent
cyber attacks on american critical
infrastructure i think just throwing out
these
insinuations at the expert level
that's that's inappropriate mr biden
said he gave putin a list of 16 u.s
infrastructure sectors like energy and
water systems and airports
that he says are off limits to attacks
if in fact they violate these basic
norms
we will respond president biden said the
world will find out within a few months
if any of putin's promises will hold
but he lost his temper when asked why he
seemed confident that putin could change
his behavior
he later apologized i shouldn't have
been such a wise guy
the last answer i gave
now that he's back in washington the
president faces significant domestic
challenges
especially the fate of his massive
infrastructure proposal
before he left here last night he said
he hasn't seen the details yet
of a significant bipartisan proposal
that's picked up
big support overnight on capitol hill
anthony ed thank you